good morning John do you remember when
you have that idea for making a channel
where you just review like not things
but ideas of things yeah I was gonna
call it the Anthropocene review I'm
gonna do that in this video who's gonna
do a bunch of them great I can't wait
see how it goes I'm excited let's start
with the city of Springfield Oregon as
viewed from an airplane
three stars entirely without apparent
intentionality too many rivers making
this base feel confined also the rivers
directionless meandering clashes with
the right angles formed by the i-5 I 105
intersection and finally how can one be
sure whether they're looking at
Springfield OR Eugene which is it I left
it behind feeling confused and unsettled
I'm sure it's lovely close up though
orange traffic cones five stars built
simultaneously for durability visibility
stability stackability and low cost the
orange traffic cone was almost an
inevitability stability can be increased
by adding heavy-duty rubber to the base
and visibility can be increased by
adding reflective collars orange traffic
cones can survive vehicle impacts in
excess of 65 miles per hour and still be
usable and yet they cost less than a gin
and tonic in Manhattan these temporary
traffic control devices have converged
upon their best possible form half-drunk
bottle of Fiji water two stars as we are
not sure who drank the first half of
this bottle of Fiji water no one is
enthusiastic about finishing it any one
of us would no doubt take it down if
there were no other options but there
are other options
the half-drunk state does however allow
one to appreciate the care with which
the design of the Fiji bottle takes
advantage of the refraction of the water
to interact with the interior printing
but on the whole I feel guilty that this
water was shipped from Fiji and now
probably no one is going to drink it
socks
five stars socks are designed for
absorbency warmth and to reduce friction
and counter-intuitively while the sock
is one of humanity's most valuable
creations the feeling of removing a sock
at the end of the day is a five-star
sensation as well socks decorative
properties while not part of their core
function are high-quality as well they
allow the wearer to make subtle yet
powerful statements the first sock in
the dftba awesome socks club
subscription for 2017 five stars
designed by Rachael Calderon Navarra
these socks are cushy durable and warm
the culmination of the testing of many
different socks
Rachel's design sense makes these socks
a subtle yet surprising pop of color at
the base of anyone's jeans sock Club
entrants are limited you'll get a new
pair of dftba socks every month but you
could only sign up during the month of
November this 1970s thermostat 3.5 stars
these handcrafted thermostats really
resonate with me it's easy to understand
how they were constructed by human hands
and the design elements were clearly
built around the necessity of their form
which was limited by the injection
molding techniques of the time but oh
hmm something seems to be off there
that's better now we're up to four stars
one wonders how long that had been off
kilter ah and let me fix this as well
that's better 4.5 stars John I'll see
you on Tuesday